Alex ' Conor the agnostic formerly known
as Cosmic skeptic has lots of
discussions and debates with Christians
and while he seems quite comfortable
criticizing Christianity he doesn't seem
nearly as interested in criticizing
Islam why is that well someone asked him
about this during the Q&A of his recent
debate with the connect Le who not
surprisingly are Christians I hadn't
seen the debate but a few nights ago
when AP and I were live one of our
viewers requested that we comment on
Alex's response so we did but some
people weren't happy with our brilliant
and completely correct comments and they
messaged me whining like babies leading
to this video so let's watch Alex answer
the question that was posed to him then
we'll see how AP and I reacted and
finally I'll share some follow-up
thoughts and assess whether Alex o Conor
is a coward for not blasting away at
Islam with the rest of us here's the
original question and Alex's
answer okay we're gonna move fast Bas
autist thanks very much says Alex I'm a
longtime fan became a Christian but I
still love your work and your honesty
I'm curious though why it seems you've
left Islam alone is this for personal
reasons or safety much love and God
bless yeah well of course it is a much
less safe thing to do that's one of the
benefits of Christianity by the way um
but I do think that uh I simply know
less about it um of course I don't
believe Islam is true and I believe it
has all kinds of problems and moral
objections that I'm sure that if I made
my moral objections to Islam plain cliff
and Shu would not want to object to my
met ethics but instead just be happy
that I was doing it um but I just know
less about it I I feel like I'm pretty
well vered in at least the New Testament
at this point
and it's mostly a consequence of that
but of course you do have to be much
more careful as well because I've never
had to fear for my safety when debating
a Christian like today pretty
straightforward he knows more about
Christianity he sounds like he knows
more about Christianity because he's
more interested in discussing
Christianity and since it's safer to
talk about Christianity why would he
want to focus much on Islam but based
autistic the same guy who asked Alex the
question asked us what we think about
his response here's what we said uh I
asked Alex ' Conor I asked Alex OK Conor
Cosmic skeptic about why he doesn't go
after Islam first question in Q&A during
most recent debate I think that's the
one he had with Cliff
connly think think I'm going through
that with on uh on Cameron's channel on
Monday haven't seen it yet but uh so he
said he asked the question he said he
prefers Christian Christianity chats but
also admitted partly it's for safety
reasons curious what are your
thoughts well um I I know already that
that is that that is the case because uh
I was in touch with him personally when
um when he made a video about about
Islam I don't remember what the what the
video was about but he made a video
about Islam about uh uh Islam's
treatment of others and so on um and the
video he took the video down after
receiving uh threats and and things like
that and I was a little bit uh
disappointed
honestly uh I messaged with him and he
said to me that
um that he he can't
really he can't really tolerate the the
the massive reactions that he gets to
any criticism of Islam and the thing is
um he said he also said that uh this
time was different because people
actually got in touch with uh somebody
very close to him and started making
personal threats against them uh after
which he decided I I just I can't do
this so he took down about it for for
for a while that's what they did with um
Venom Fang X back in the day when he
made his uh he made videos making fun of
Muhammad and they threatened him and he
kept making the videos eventually they
contacted his parents at their work and
threatened their parent his parents at
their work he was still a teenager and
so he took down his Islam stuff because
they were actually threatening his
parents and so on so anyway it's uh
there are always efforts on the part of
Islam to silence anyone who disagrees
with what they want and they have
multiple ways of doing that the the most
obvious way is just harassing people and
threatening them if that doesn't work
then they'll then they'll start me
contacting people who are close to you
um guys I'm actually fine with uh with
Alex saying hey you know what uh I don't
want to I don't want to deal with these
guys these guys might kill me you might
say ah but you know we have to stand up
that's true it doesn't have to be Alex
he's pretty recognizable guy he would be
extremely recognizable in public so even
though people need to stand up against
this not everyone needs to do it if
they're going to be especially in danger
where they are so anyway if he I mean
keep in mind back in the day hijab was
like saying where he lived and stuff
like this so that's uh that's credible
and he's an
atheist or an agnostic now I don't know
I know he's he's been shifting his level
of aggression and hostility uh over the
past couple years but uh you know at the
end of the day at the end of the day
atheists you believe that your life ends
at death so you probably don't want to
be a martyr against Islam let the
Christians will take care of that for
you let the Christians take care of that
for you so
I think I like Alex where he is and what
he does right now I think he's a very
good uh very very very very good
interlocutor and a very good interviewer
and and uh thinker and all that I think
he's doing a fantastic job in seeking
and and uh you know discussing different
ideas and and so on so I think um he's
he's he's doing a he's doing a very good
job and uh not everyone has to be the
the enemy so AP and I are totally fine
with Alex saying there are topics that
I'm more interested in than Islam and as
an added bonus it's safer to talk about
those other topics but not everyone is
satisfied with Alex's position and they
raise two main criticisms if I were to
Steelman the main criticisms of Alex's
position they would go something like
this first entire cities in the UK are
being taken over by is as we speak if
Alex thinks it's dangerous to criticize
Islam now imagine what it's going to be
like a generation or two down the road
is this the best time for Christians and
atheists to be arguing about the
existence of God or would this be a
really good time for Christians and
atheists to recognize that it doesn't
matter who wins a debate about the
existence of God if we're about to be
violently subjugated and forced to
comply with the ramblings of an
illiterate 7th Century Arabian Caravan
van robber Alex likes having discussions
but if Islam wins he won't be allowed to
have discussions on the topics he's
interested in Islam is a threat to
everything Alex wants to do in life as a
rule if someone is attacking the
foundations of your civilization the
foundations of your rights and freedoms
you drop whatever else you're doing and
deal with that threat in other words if
this isn't exactly D-Day it's pretty
close to D-Day so anyone who doesn't
take a stand against the threat is a
traitor to his own
civilization that's my Steel Man of one
of the criticisms here's the other there
are lots of people comedians for
instance who will criticize or mock
Christianity or Mormonism or this or
that political party but they won't say
a word about Islam because they don't
want any attention from jihadis so they
only attack safe targets why is this a
problem well when you attack people who
don't threaten you but you don't say a
word about people who threaten you
you're basically rewarding violent
Behavior you're saying in effect if you
want to control our speech if you want
to always get your way just start
threatening us and we'll do exactly what
you want and that not only rewards
violent Behavior it encourages more
violent Behavior so when people try to
control you with threats and
intimidation don't give them an inch on
the contrary if people try to control
you with violence you should do the
opposite of what they want in order to
discourage threats and
intimidation those are the two main
objections to someone saying I don't
talk much about Islam because I'm more
interested in other things and more
knowledgeable about other things and
it's just safer to talk about other
things and generally speaking there's
some truth in these objections there is
a rapidly growing threat to Great
Britain and there are people who reward
bad behavior by criticizing or mocking
ideologies that won't respond violently
while treating the world's most
dangerous ideology with kids
gloves however you can't tell one young
British agnostic that he has to shoulder
the burden of saving a nation that's
bent on destroying itself British
politicians police journalists Educators
they're begging to be subjugated in fact
they're much more hostile towards
someone who's criticizing Islam than
they are towards some daa clown who's
openly proclaiming that he wants capital
punishment for
apostasy this is a part of our religion
there's a reason to it yeah there's a
reason why there's a capital punishment
because people like you little weaklings
who leave their religion and cause uh
corruption in the land by spreading it
the capital punishment in Islamic law
would be applied to you we have no doubt
and we're proud of that yeah Capital
punish will be applied in an Islamic
State yeah not individuals going and
doing it theel like idiots yeah no under
an Amir it is done yes and we you know
what we'll be watching we'll be watching
because if you're going to cause
corruption in the land that's going to
cause more damage to the society as a
whole because sh didn't come to protect
an individuals right hey can I drink
alcohol yeah sure drink alcohol run
someone over kill them set the all this
kind of chaos no Islam says the right of
the community is greater than you
individual wanting your right to Freedom
which is BS Pop Quiz imagine two people
person one is a dawa guy who openly
declares that he wants Islamic law in
Great Britain and that he wants to watch
Mass public executions of apostates and
critics of Islam person two is a random
British factory worker who posts a
message on Facebook saying that if the
da guy wants Islamic law he should go to
Afghanistan which of these two
individuals is more likely to be thrown
in prison for expressing his
views we all know the answer because
that's how screwed up Great Britain has
become why would anyone think that Alex
oconor should martyr him himself for
people who will absolutely hate him and
declare war on him for trying to save
them Great Britain's problem is much
bigger than Islam that problem isn't
going to be fixed by some kid in his 20s
painting a giant Target on his back yes
we need to deal with the problem and in
an Ideal World people would be United in
confronting sick evil ideologies but
this isn't an Ideal World so we need to
understand the situation and not be
stupid here's what I would
propose if you're an atheist or an
agnostic and you live in an area where
criticizing Islam could put you in
danger probably not a good idea to be a
vocal critic of Islam of course if
you're aware of the risks and you want
to go after Islam I'm not your boss but
if you have other things that you want
to accomplish in life focus on those
other things and let the rest of us
expose Muhammad and the Quran now for
those of you who want to face the
Islamic Challenge and you live in a
place where you can criticize Islam
without seriously endangering yourself
and those around you you might want to
dial things up a few notches learn some
facts about Muhammad and expose him
learn some facts about the Quran and
expose it by doing so you'll not only be
weakening ISL Islam you'll be protecting
other people who are criticizing Islam
if a few people are making fun of
Muhammad it's easy to Target them if
tons of people are making fun of
Muhammad threats and intimidation don't
work as well let me give you a personal
example of what I mean after college my
friend Nabil keshi left Islam and
converted to Christianity what a great
picture of him coming out of the water
after his
baptism what you might not know is that
about a month later he got his first
death threat it was attached to his car
over time he received many more threats
and I had to think to myself
H my best friend is in danger and I'm
partly responsible for the danger he's
in because I was the one telling him to
leave Islam and follow Jesus I played a
role in his life and even though he made
the correct Choice he was always going
to be in
danger was there anything I could do
about that yes yes there was I could
make sure that I was always a more
attractive Target for jihadis than nael
was I could make sure that if some
Jihadi decided to impress Allah by
slaughtering someone he would think of
me before he thought of Nabil so I was
pretty brutal when I went after Muhammad
and the Quran but I knew that as long as
I was still walking around running my
mouth my friend was safe and I knew I
was succeeding because I ended up
getting way way more threats than
the I still have that same basic
mentality although it's a bit trickier
now because pretty much all of my
friends are under some sort of death
sentence from Islam either for apostasy
or for criticizing Islam or for both
so I try to make sure I'm the best
Target AP is the one who makes it
difficult he does the same things I do
but he's also an apostate and I've seen
recently that some of these Sharia files
are angrier at him than they are at me
which means I may need to escalate and I
will it won't be in the way you think
but I'll point it out after I'm done and
you'll say whoa that was
brilliant so consider this basic
principle if you're in a relatively safe
place and you expose Islam you're
helping people who aren't as safe as you
are if jihadis are focused on you
because you're annoying them that frees
up some other people who aren't on the
Jihadi
radar along those lines I'd say that
this principle applies more to
Christians than it applies to atheists
or agnostics we have as our Supreme
moral example a man who laid down his
life for others I'm not saying that you
should be stupid or that you should
needlessly endanger yourself but I am
saying that if someone has to put
himself In Harm's Way to protect someone
else it should be a Christian shielding
someone like Alex and not Alex shielding
a Christian so let that young man have
his discussions and attack
Christianity while we do everything we
can to make sure he's never attacked by
jihadis
[Music]